what's going on guys this is rob and uh
this video is gonna have spoilers fyi so
uh first things first my bad about the
thumbnail
for last week's video um i didn't even
put two and two together and in all
honesty the significance of cad bane had
largely been lost on me because i never
really watched clone wars or even star
wars rebels i'm an episode four five and
six guy right i mean i saw the first
three movies and i was like i mean okay
like they're okay but like they don't
have new the gravitas or the development
or just just the downright just
greatness of like you know episodes four
five and six yes i'm in that crowd i
will not apologize right i will die on
this on this mountain like there's no
way you're ever gonna get me to come off
of this thing but uh having said that
yeah so that's my mistake with that with
that thumbnail i usually try to avoid
spoilers and thumbnails if i can so uh
so yeah that's that's that's my mistake
many apologies
but let's talk about uh let's talk about
boba fett right so here's the thing
right the openings seem like when
they're all talking about where they're
gonna fight and all that kind of stuff i
mean that's cool i guess i mean i feel
like boba fett was kind of an idiot for
even entertaining the idea of like going
back to uh going back to like the palace
and fighting there when it's obvious
that if he did the people in that town
would lose faith in him everything else
about the episode was phenomenal now
here's one thing that i that i wasn't
the biggest fan of right one thing that
i wasn't the biggest fan of was cad bane
showing up there
just at all right and even telling boba
fett like i kill the marshall and
there's no reinforcements coming or
anything like that i understand why they
did that in order to basically set up
like a conflict
basically where boba fett could like get
his revenge on cad bane like i
understand that and and that's cool and
everything um but i think it would have
been a lot more riveting and a lot more
interesting if like we as the audience
even kind of being left on a cliffhanger
to a degree regarding the reinforcements
at the end of the last episode of
whether or not they will actually show
up we kind of knew they were going to
right just the look on the dude's face
the idea that like usually when it comes
to somebody doing what cad bane and the
syndicate did right by taking out the
marshall all they did was like give the
the townspeople a free town more
motivation to show up and actually fight
alongside boba fett where previously
they weren't even 100 sure that they
were going to do it but barring that
boba fett and like the mandalorian all
them were banking on the reinforcements
showing up so the benefit of cad bane
not being there and not telling them
that wouldn't necessarily be for boba
fett in them it would be for us because
while boba fett and them were like yeah
man reinforcements are coming we're just
kind of like i mean are they though
because like you know cadbane killed the
marshall it would have been a lot more
riveting and a lot more exciting uh that
being said
everything else it was great right i
love the way everything unfolded in this
episode right so going into this idea
and we're gonna let's just call in the
heads of the five families right just go
full godfather here the idea that they
had all basically turned against boba
fett and sided with the syndicate again
like it was pointed out by the
mandalorian it was a smart move to do
that right it was the smart call to do
that and i loved that right i love that
whole that whole exchange that idea that
like basically all these different
groups are turning against them more so
than that using guerrilla warfare
tactics that's genius right the idea
that like it's not people who are going
out there in like obvious uniforms
because they represent these different
families and you know it's easy to point
them out from other people but the fact
that they're basically just townspeople
who reach into a basket and pull out a
repeater and just start shooting at them
right it was it was cool to see that
whole thing go down this was even more
significant by the fact that like like
literally everybody was just boxed in in
different locations right they were
basically trapped in different locations
and for a moment it was like are any of
them going to be safe now here's one of
the things that was kind of
disappointing not in the sense that it
took away from the show but in the sense
that it's something that i really wanted
to see happen and it didn't the moment
between boba fett and the mandalorian
and i can't be the only one who wanted
to hear this right but like that moment
like we know boba fett doesn't really
buy into like the whole mandalorian
creed and all that kind of stuff he
considers it to just be sort of nonsense
essentially but like the mandalorian
believes in that stuff and the
mandalorian when him and boba fett are
having that discussion and boba fett's
like i mean like are you gonna stay here
and fight the mandalorians like yeah
like i'm gonna stay here i'm gonna fight
alongside you because like it's the
right thing to do basically you know and
so like it's like the mandalorian was
like this is the way
i was so hoping boba fett would say this
is the way not because he actually
believes it but like as a sign of
respect to the mandalorian for staying
there and fighting alongside him it
would have been great right if like if
mandalorian bit like this is the way and
boba fett's like this is the way and
like that that would have been it right
it doesn't mean like he's fully adopting
the mandalorian philosophies anymore but
like what it does mean is he's like i
respect you right like i'm i'm
respecting the fact that you're here and
i am honoring your creed by by saying
like this is the way right you know i'm
honoring this this level of respect
having said that what we locked in that
we we got in like the two of them
fighting together let me tell you
something man that was some straight up
goku and vegeta it was legit seeing
these two guys fighting alongside each
other right like just shooting up into
like into the air like their rocket
packs and everything it was cool that
was really really amazing and i i loved
it what i also loved too and this this
is something that i feel like has been
pretty consistent with ming na win
really ever since the movie push which
if you never saw push it was a great
movie right chris evans and dakota
fanning i think ming na win and it had a
lot of like great cast members right
dakota johnson i think was in it it was
it was it was a great it was a
phenomenal film really really underrated
but like since that movie and like going
into like especially agents of shield
and so on she's always just kind of been
the badass and i love that she's the one
that just saves everybody's ass like all
the people who were all basically pinned
down like she saves them essentially
rescues them and gets them out uh it's
it's cool like that was a really really
cool moment there but like literally for
the most part the idea that like it's
just kind of this ongoing conflict right
the giant battle droids with the shields
and so on and so forth that largely went
the way that i expected it to right i
mean it's just literally them just kind
of fleeing for their lives to agree and
like fighting where they can when they
can and holding them off the cool thing
was like when boba fett took off and
he's like i gotta find reinforcements i
was like okay is it is he gonna go to
like mos eisley because there's no way
he's gonna make it there and back in
time like that's not gonna happen like
where the hell is he going i never saw
the raincore coming and in fact i forgot
about it
i can't be the only one but i forgot
about the raincore by the time like we
got to this episode and that was cool
right boba fett just like riding into
the battlefield on a raincore and like
just crushing these battle droids that
was great right obviously a little bit
of hell a little bit of assistance there
from the mandalorian with the dark saber
but nonetheless i thought that was great
that was phenomenal and one of the
things that i that i really loved about
this whole thing and this is especially
prevalent with like the return of grogu
was the fact that like all eyes were on
boba fett and his supporting cast right
again this is really important with
grogu and the reason why is because it
would have been very very easy for them
to write this episode in such a way
where like everyone's boxed in and like
no one really has a chance and then here
comes grogu with like his force powers
let the conflict end right force crush
everything like it would have been very
easy for them to write that to write
that set of events playing out they
didn't though i mean there's obviously a
couple reasons for this right grogu's
training is just painfully incomplete
that grogu chose the mandalorian over
the path of the jedi and like that's why
he's there i mean you know there's
obvious reasons why that wasn't the case
but more so than that had they done that
right had they had grogu show up with
just like godly force powers and just
like defeating everything in sight it
would have taken all the emphasis away
from the capabilities of boba fett and
the supporting cast and all those guys
and it largely would have made them look
inept right and so the fact they didn't
do that was just a stroke of genius but
i mean goku did a little bit right he
ripped a bolt out of the knee of like
the of like the battle droid
so like that was cool right he basically
he basically like he kicked him in the
knee right he swept the leg for all you
uh karate kid fans
uh you know it was it was cool to see
him do that but by and large he was just
kind of offering assistance here in
there and so ultimately again you know
the whole thing going on you know the
the conflict playing out and so on and
so forth the raincore going mad that was
cool and then i will say what was also
really cool was basically grogu like
bringing the raincore down right that
was pretty cool and okay here's the
here's the thing i'm not even i'm not
even gonna lie here right like
when grogu bought brought down the
raincore it was it was hey big guy
the sun's getting real low
it was like that kind of a thing but
like it also just kind of occurred to me
i kind of want to see like a grogu and
rancor adventure show
who knows what adventures they'll get
into
grogu and rancor invite you right the
adventures of grogu and rancor i would
love to see that show
i'm not even gonna lie i would love to
see that show just like a grogu and
rancor buddy cop movie like han solo and
chewbacca like i would want to see that
right i thought i think that would be
like really really amazing but all in
all you know everything taken into
account especially like like finnick was
like she basically pulled like a michael
corleone at the end of the movie right
you guys remember godfather michael
corleone was he was talking to his
brother-in-law right the one who was
beating on his sister and was like today
i settle all family business right he
took out like mo green and like strategy
and like bodzini and all those guys
right took out everybody and the whole
and like in the whole family uh
that's kind of what happened here right
finnick shows up and basically kills
everybody right like everybody dies the
mayor dies the heads of the five
families die uh like the the head of the
syndicate at least seemingly on on in
muscle isley he's dead right like all
those guys are taken out so like
seemingly tattooing is like a place free
from the influence of the syndicate how
long that will go on for i don't really
know because we don't even know if the
syndicate is working alongside any other
like bigger organizations like organized
crime organizations because one of the
things you guys probably know from just
being aware of star wars is everything
feeds everything else so like if the
syndicate disappears a lot of people are
going to lose money and if those people
are losing money they're going to want
to know why and they're going to show up
on tatooine
so it kind of gives you the ability to
sort of see these sort of continuing
conflicts taking place on the planet in
the aftermath of the syndicate being
ousted that was pretty cool but as far
as the ending goes and this is what's
the most intriguing about me obviously
they can take it a couple different ways
right if they were to say for example
that like the mandalorian took baby yoda
and the two of them just rode off into
the sunset that answers the question why
it is that grogu was not present when
the knights of ren basically massacred
everybody and then took off right uh at
the same time though it also kind of
makes sense that the ending would be the
mandalorian taking grogu to luke
skywalker and he would basically do it
from a place that's not necessarily
doing it begrudgingly and from an
emotional place like he was at the end
of mandalorian season two where he's
like i mean you're supposed to go grogu
you know
you know tear drops i don't really don't
want to see you leave it's not really
anything like that where at this point
it's just kind of like a resolute thing
right like you really do belong with
with those people right you belong with
the jedi you need to go train with luke
skywalker i know you don't want to leave
me and i will cherish our memories
forever but like this is where you
belong right this is this is who you're
supposed to be with i'm not really sure
which way it goes and honestly i'm going
to leave it to you guys right which
direction do you guys think they're
going with this ending do you think
mandalorian is taking grogu back to luke
skywalker or do you think it's just
mandalorian and grogu riding off into
the sunset and they're basically gonna
be there in mandalorian season three let
me know which one you guys think it's
gonna be and also let me know what you
guys thought about the series down in
the comments section but thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace